the next-gen version of cyberpunk 2077
is still on track for the end of 2021
with a little bit of wiggle room no
man's sky has finally released the
frontiers update brendan greene the
creator of pubg is starting a brand new
studio and the tokyo game show schedule
is now live i'm persia and this is
today's gamespot news update
plenty of big 2021 games have been
delayed to 2022 mostly because of the
pandemic but cd projekt red said the
playstation 5 and xbox series xns
versions of cyberpunk 2077 and the
witcher 3 remain on track for release
this year it was said on an earnings
call that cyberpunk 2077's next-gen
version still has a target date of late
2021 but at the same time keeping in
mind the lessons we have learned during
the past year and taking into account
that this project still remains in
development we can't say with full
certainty that the production schedule
will not change and a similar sentiment
was shared in regards to the witcher 3.
cyberpunk 2077's ps5 and xbox series xns
additions will take advantage of the
additional horsepower of those systems
to make the game look and run better and
the same is true for the witcher 3. the
game is gonna come with all of the
previously released expansions and even
includes some new content inspired by
netflix's hit witcher tv show
no man's sky's latest updates have been
explosive and really awesome we've
gotten new pets we've got new gameplay
modes and even more but the newest
update frontiers is going to possibly
have a bigger impact on the game than
any of the ones before it frontiers
which players can download right now
adds a settlement system to no man's sky
letting players build their own town
that they can manage on an alien planet
players won't be able to plop their own
settlement down wherever they'd like but
will instead have to earn the title of
overseer at an existing one the role of
a town overseer includes sorting out all
kinds of disputes resolving arguments
between villagers defending the town
from attacking sentinels and more
players who manage to keep their
settlements happy and productive will
earn some resources every day
frontiers is also giving no man's sky
players the tools they need to build a
unique settlement or base really easily
base building has received multiple
updates including a new building menu
placement modes and over 250 new parts
sean murray said on twitter we're
excited for what it allows us to do in
the future
which means frontiers may not be the end
for new content in no man's sky
but it does mean the end of having the
developers face being modded into the
game we've got the full list of patch
notes and all of the other new details
over on gamespot.com
[Music]
brynden green better known by his online
persona player unknown has officially
announced that he will be leaving the
pub g developer and publisher crafton to
form his own independent studio player
unknown productions in 2019 green moved
to amsterdam to set up playerunknown's
productions under crafton's pubg
corporation moving away from development
on pubg to work on new projects
now player unknown productions will
officially be splitting from crafton to
become an independent studio with
crafton holding a minority stake in the
studio the studio's first project
prologue was announced at the 2019 game
awards though it's unclear whether the
project will be impacted by the studio's
split green said in a press release
today i'm excited to take the next step
on my journey to create the kind of
experience i've envisaged for years
again i'm thankful for everyone at
crafton for supporting my plans and i'll
have more to reveal about our project at
a later date the press release adds that
the team over at playerunknown
productions are researching systems
needed to enable massive scale in
multiplayer games
konami capcom square enix and so many
more are among the lists that have
appeared on the schedule for tokyo game
show there aren't too many details about
every presentation just yet but square
enix has confirmed its dedicated tokyo
game show segment that will offer the
latest news about their upcoming titles
along with pre-announced information
the square in extreme will take place on
october 1st at 3 a.m pacific 6 a.m
eastern and will run for just under an
hour square enix has no shortage of
games that could make an appearance
including marvel's guardians of the
galaxy final fantasy 14's in walker
expansion that's due out in november and
several mobile games such as final
fantasy the first soldier and hitman
sniper the shadows
microsoft will also host a showcase at
the tokyo game show with a 50 minute
event on september 30th that's titled
the xbox tokyo game show showcase 2021
you'll have to be up early for that one
as it's scheduled to be streamed at 2
a.m pacific and 5 a.m eastern not every
presentation has been announced or
confirmed just yet as a lot of the slots
on the schedule are still to be
determined but make sure you subscribe
because we're gonna be keeping you up to
date on all the tokyo game show news as
it comes in
i'm definitely ready to hop into no
man's sky today and become a space mayor
but honestly with cyberpunk on the mind
i'm really curious to know from you guys
what do you think about the next-gen
versions and what exactly is it going to
take to get you to hop back in if you've
decided to step away let me know down
below in the comments and of course
thank you so much for tuning in again
and i'll see you tomorrow for your next
update
you